the press
it looks like angrier Lorax Donald Trump
might be the first president of the
great again States of America to avoid
the media by holding press conferences
solely on social media it's like his own
weekly tweet the press even explained
why he tweets in a tweet he tweeted
yesterday on Twitter if the press would
cover me accurately and honorably I
would have far less reason to tweet
quote-unquote sadly I don't know if that
will ever happen
what meow take that the press so
comedians I want to know what Donald
Trump will say on the next tweet the
press all the rest of our year's budget
Mike Lawrence does anyone know how to
run the world's most powerful government
asking for a friend
yeah
[Applause]